[Music]  hey was someone in Samuel Leeds we're  looking for people to join a creative  and media team I'll put a post up I  think it was about three days ago saying  that we're looking for journalists we're  looking for video directors film makers  people that are creative to join the  Samuel lids team absolutely been  bombarded since today we moved to London  we now get our offices in London and we  need people now the thing is we only  want people that are absolutely  excellent so if you are in the creative  space is what we need to do create  something amazing make your video do a  picture I don't know why do something  really creative show us your best work  show us how awesome you are and then use  this hashtag post it on social media  using this hashtag if it blows me away  and it blows the team away we will come  and find you and I hope to work with you  real soon in a London baby get posting  use the hashtag will come find you  [Music]